this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
sign up for the nebula bundle deal for
just 1479 at curiositystream.com forward
slash
real engineering to get access to our
nine part logistics of d-day series
the lion's share of attention in our
quest to neutralize carbon emissions in
the transport industry
has always been on road transport it's
technology we interact with
every day it's visceral the smell sound
and sight of the internal combustion
engine is near
inescapable but if we actually take the
time to examine the world's carbon
emissions
we start to see some less obvious
polluters that don't get as much
mainstream attention
yes road transport accounts for around
12 of our total greenhouse gas emissions
and we have the technology to reduce
that to zero
but what about the other 88 percent
there are many industries around the
world
working to neutralize their carbon
footprint and each is coming up with
ingenious and novel technologies
to get them closer to that target one of
those industries
the shipping industry is responsible for
around two percent of the world's
emissions
the vast majority of this is created by
container ships
which carry 80 of the world's trade
astoundingly there aren't millions of
cargo ships hauling our commodities
around the world
mursk the world's largest shipping
company with 17.6 percent of the world's
market share of container transport
only has 786 ships 786
gigantic ships these ships typically
last 20 to 30 years
so it's important that we are prepared
to convert these ships to carbon neutral
technology
when their time comes the largest ship
in the maersk fleet
the triple e is the same length as the
empire state building
the scale of these ships is mind blowing
a single triple e
is capable of hauling over 20 000 teu
which means it can carry 20 000 standard
20-foot containers to put that into more
human terms
a single 20 foot container can hold
about 6 000
shoe boxes so a single triple e shipment
could deliver over 123 million pairs of
shoes
enough to fit nearly every single person
in japan
that's insane it's easy to see these
ships as gigantic pollution machines
each one of these ships has an
astounding impact on global emissions
maersk as a whole released over 36.5
million metric tons of carbon dioxide in
2019
roughly equivalent to a small country's
emissions like ireland
but to give credit where credit is due
cargo ships are astoundingly efficient
much more efficient than any other form
of transport
this figure was closer to six grams in
2007
but maersk didn't invent some
revolutionary technology to achieve this
they just slow down fuel consumption of
these ships
is primarily a function of their size
weight and speed
this graph shows the relative fuel
consumption per day
at different speeds and cargo capacities
the fuel consumption rises
exponentially with each knot of speed
added and the heavier
the ship the more pronounced that fuel
increase is
an 8 000 teu container ship traveling at
24 knots would be expected to burn
225 tons of fuel per day
but a reduction in speed of just 12.5
to 21 knots would result in a 33
decline in fuel consumption to 150 tons
per day
the practice of lowering speeds began in
2007
not because of climate change concerns
but as a result of rising fuel prices
and then in 2008 the practice was
fortified by the arrival
of the financial crisis placing
financial strain on the world economy
to survive and lower costs shipping
companies looked towards
lower fuel consumption and the trend
continues today as climate change has
come
into focus that 42 reduction in
emissions
is great but getting to 60 by 2030
and 100 by 2050 as maersk aims to do
won't be easy slowing down a ship to
reduce fuel consumption
is a game of diminishing returns below
12 to 15 knots and it just
doesn't make sense and to achieve 100
with this method
we would just need to turn off our
engines a good way to collapse the
world's economy
so what's the plan to get to 100 percent
[Music]
something interesting happened when
these ships started to slow down
their carefully shaped hulls stopped
working as designed
the hulls of huge ships like this are
shaped very carefully to minimize drag
but at a particular operating speed
lowering the speed of the ships
messed with the fluid dynamics and
prevented some drag reducing designs
from working properly the bulbous bow is
a particularly important
efficiency device for large ships
capable of reducing drag by up to 15
they are by no means a new technology
the first ones were fitted to ships like
the uss delaware
all the way back in 1910 and they work
by producing
a secondary bow wave which acts through
destructive interference
to negate the primary wave created by
the whole
of the ship in simple terms this
technology reduces the energy that is
being lost
to wave creation and also reduces
frictional drag
as the contact area the ship has with
the water is reduced
the range of operating speeds for a
typical ship in 2007
was pretty narrow today the speeds are
not only lower but
far more variable bows that were
designed for this speed
simply won't work as desired at this
speed
so as part of maersk's fuel saving
efforts they began retrofitting their
bulbous bows for ones better suited for
the new
lower operating speeds in 2012
getting an industry like this to clean
up their act
starts by increasing efficiencies with a
machine
this large efficiency has to be our
primary focus
in lowering emissions it's low hanging
fruit that can
as we have seen result in millions of
tons of fuel
being saved there is a huge number of
technologies being developed
with this goal in mind one particularly
interesting shift we are seeing in the
industry is towards a return of wind
power
to offer additional thrust to these
massive ships
a centuries-old technology that once
powered shipping empires like the dutch
west india company it's difficult to
integrate wind power into modern ships
shipping companies won't incorporate
them if they take up too much space
which could be used for cargo and
designing them in a manner that allows
for a timely return on investment is
difficult
one particularly interesting form of
wind power which is currently being
tested
is the flatner rotor these rotors use
the magnus effect
to generate thrust which is the force
experienced by a rotating object as a
result of the deflected airflow around
it
when presented with a crosswind these
rotors can provide a good deal of thrust
for very little energy input modern
composite materials have allowed the
rotors to be much lighter and thus
take less power to spin according to
norse power
their largest rotors can provide up to
three megawatts of forward thrust
for an input of just 90 kilowatts of
electricity
critically they are simple in
construction minimizing costs
they take up a minimal space on the deck
minimizing loss of revenue
can be easily retrofitted to many
different types of ships
and the rotors are controlled by a
computer requiring
little to no input from the ship's crew
these rotors are currently being tested
on a maersk tanker and between
september 2018 and september 2019
saved 8.2 percent of their fuel if that
is repeatable
i can't imagine it will be long before
we see these devices being fitted to
more ships on routes
with favorable prevailing winds of
course
wind isn't going to power these ships by
itself we can only get fuel consumption
so low and this is where the shipping
industry faces its biggest challenge
fuel traditionally the shipping industry
has used this horrible pollutive heavy
sludge like fuel
literally bottom of the barrel quality
fuel cheap
but incredibly dirty releasing heavily
polluting sulfur and nitrous oxides into
the air
the international maritime organization
mandated that these emissions
need to be reduced and the shipping
industry has primarily responded
by turning to low sulfur heavy fuel oil
fitting scrubber systems to remove the
pollutants from the exhaust
while others are turning to liquefied
natural gas
the largest liquefied natural
gas-powered ship launched
just two months ago which will all but
eliminate many of the problems
associated with heavy fuel oils
and result in about 20 percent less
carbon emissions
but they are leaking a large amount of
methane into the atmosphere
a much more potent greenhouse gas at the
end of the day
this fuel is still a fossil fuel we
could switch to biofuels like biogas or
biodiesel
these are both fuels that are derived
using renewable methods
of converting biomass into fuel but
their ability to eliminate carbon
emissions are debatable
some methods help reduce the net carbon
dioxide output
and others are worse for the environment
than fossil fuels
biofuels like biodiesel unless carefully
regulated
are completely pointless and could just
encourage the conversion
of even more woodland areas into
farmland to grow soya beans
while barely reducing our carbon
emissions i'm not convinced biofuels are
the answer
but i need to look into the subject in
more detail to have a more solid opinion
on the topic
hydrogen is also an option but comes
with the usual disadvantages
primarily that it is currently very
expensive
but that hasn't stopped countries like
norway and japan
from placing their bets in hydrogen for
industries like this
the shipping industry much like the
long-haul trucking industry
can take advantage of the hub to hub
nature of the cargo hauling industry
and build out critical infrastructure
along single heavy use routes first
japan is one of the primary refuelling
stops
for the high traffic trans-pacific route
connecting the two largest economies in
the world
china and the united states this route
as a result of its length
poses some interesting logistic
challenges in a transition
to hydrogen because while hydrogen has a
high gravimetric
energy density its volumetric energy
density is quite low
meaning ships would need to sacrifice
some cargo space
for fuel storage one study found that
about 43
of voyages on the trans-pacific route
could be completed
without replacing cargo space with fuel
storage
or making an additional refueling stop
they also found that if two percent of
the cargo space
was replaced with fuel storage 86
of voyages could be made as normal and 5
would allow 99 of voyages to continue as
normal
alternatively 99 of trips could be made
by making one extra refueling stop where
that fueling stop can be
for a roost this long poses more
problems a large detour to refueling
stations in alaska would cut into
profits
perhaps if demand allows it floating
refueling stations with their own
hydrogen generation
powered by offshore wind could service
routes like this
and allow for the shortest route between
china and the usa
to continue being used thankfully the
shipping industry is already pretty
efficient but there is always room to
improve
this will take investment and will cut
into the shipping industry's profits
as fuel prices rise but these are
necessary moves to not only reduce
but eliminate our carbon emissions as we
saw the only reason these shipping
companies began to move away from heavy
fuel
is because the international maritime
organization mandated it
we need to continue putting pressure on
companies to not only clean up their
technology
but be ready for the next step these are
big machines that will be sailing our
oceans for decades
making the wrong move now and betting on
a fuel that ultimately isn't better for
the environment
and isn't scalable is a problem we will
have to live with for decades
we need to be future focused and make
the right decisions today
the shipping industry is the backbone of
our modern world
shipping products from all over the
world from food
to fuel the modern economy would simply
grind to a halt
without this service the liberty ships
of world war ii
are arguably the most influential
technology developed
during the war cheap and quick to build
they allowed the united states to act
as the manufacturing hub for the allies
on all fronts
transporting thousands of tanks men fuel
and supplies across the atlantic
and pacific oceans in our nine-part
series
available exclusively to nebula we
explore how logistics
like this shaped one of the most pivotal
battles of world war ii
d-day in this two and a half hour long
series we
explored the unique ships the allies
used to get ashore
and the secret floating harbours they
built and towed
across the english channel why normandy
was chosen
and how they broke through the defenses
to get their men ashore
how engineers rushed from the beaches to
build airfields and fuel pipelines
and repair the railways in our final
episode released
this month we explored how the allies
managed to supply the front line
as it marched closer and closer to
germany
this is just the first series we plan to
make for nebula
and season two is already in the works
where we will be exploring the battle of
britain
in the same nerdy detail the best way to
watch this series and ensure that future
projects like this can be
funded is by signing up for the
curiosity stream and nebula bundle deal
here you will get access to both
platforms for just 1479 a year
a great deal that will get you access to
this series add free videos from your
favorite
youtube creators nebula exclusives and
new
exclusive podcasts like show makers
where sam from wendover productions and
i
interview some of your favorite youtube
creators about their life
as youtubers what's insane is that you
get all that for free
because it's bundled with curiosity
stream which has loads of award-winning
documentaries itself
you